[Music]
[Music]
hey guys so why would I ever write a
book again that is this big I had no
plans to write travel mentors but this
past year I turned 40 and a lot happened
in the last say 18 months a number of
very close friends died I've had some
very intense family issues in my
extended family and all those things led
me in addition to growing out my
mystical beard to reassess my life and
to want to take a step back and do a
30,000 foot view and ask a lot of really
big questions and these tend to be the
kind of questions that I ask and many
people ask at different key Forks in the
road right or many many Forks in the
road where might be college graduation
might be at the end of a first job after
the end of your first major relationship
or midlife crisis retirement and so on
and I realized that I was still
struggling with a lot of things that
were long-standing how to be kinder to
myself how to say no how to separate the
signal from the noise so of course as
you get more successful as anyone even
has a small amount of success your
problems don't go away you just trade up
so you used to have the say Pinto of
problems then you get the corolla of
problems then you get the Mercedes of
problems and also your attackers and
detractors getting more and more
sophisticated powerful and so on I was
looking for help I was looking for help
sorting out what the next 40 years might
look like and for you that could be you
could be 20 you could be 80 the
questions are the same many of the
questions are the same and I had a
certain mentor group but I found myself
trying to do it on my own and I knew a
lot of the same people very very smart
but I dreamed of reaching out to certain
folks like what would Dan Gable
legendary wrestling coach who was a
demigod to me growing up what would he
do in this scenario how would he think
about physical training after a certain
age when maybe your joints aren't what
they used to be
or if I wanted to 10x 100x my results
what would one of the founders of
Facebook say or on a day-to-day basis
with tools they find most useful or do
they travel with all these types of
questions led me to then ask myself all
right I'm trying to do too much heavy
lifting on my own what would this look
like if it were easy the answer I came
up with and journaling was reaching out
to a dream list of people and asking
them all the same 11 questions or so
some of them I'd refined through the
podcast Tim Ferriss show now is more
than 200 million download so how did she
has to really get to a surgical
precision of certain questions and then
a bunch that I wanted to add what do you
do when you feel unfocused or
overwhelmed specifically what do you do
or what questions do you ask yourself
how do you say no how have you built the
rules for yourself or systems to say no
to more things and so on and that's how
we ended up with tri-band Mentors how
did I choose people it's a really really
eclectic group of people and I actually
want to read one quote at the very very
beginning that I thought was very
important and relevant to my life in
this book and this is from Marcel Proust
P Rous T quote the only true voyage
would be not to travel through a hundred
different lands with the same pair of
eyes but to see the same land through a
hundred different pairs of eyes and to
have a different lens through which to
look at your challenges problems
opportunities relationships so I found
130 or so of them and I wanted to cover
everything I wanted to cover health
wealth happiness Fitness longevity
everything imaginable thinking systems
so it ranges from say writers and
teachers Steven Pressfield Susan Cain
people that you may know like Terry
Crews for instance all of their lessons
Matt Ridley bazooms Saint John ayaan
Hirsi Ali it's a long list but then
there are people you might not recognize
and what I found if you look at say the
podcast of the top six episodes of all
time three of them 50% are of people or
involving people you probably didn't
hear of before the podcast so I'd say at
least
well first of all 95% of the people in
the book have not been on the podcast
and then at least half of them you've
probably never heard of but it includes
the creators of etherium all these icons
of cryptocurrency actors and so on like
Ben Stiller then you have CrossFit
champions Neil Gaiman temple grandin
athletes like Kelly Slater who has the
distinction of I think being the
youngest person ever to win the
equivalent of a world championship and
surfing and then the oldest alright so
how do you do that right what books have
informed his thinking and training and
so on also one of the things that I did
is as I collected answers and
interviewed people if a name came up
repeatedly I would go after that name so
say Steven Pinker you have say the
authors of sapiens and Matt Ridley and
so on
all these names kept recurring so I
reached out to them so you'll find as
you read this book as they mentioned
mentors influences books and so on
they're tied to other people in the book
there's this entire web mesh of
knowledge and patterns so a few people
who have read this book my close friends
like Matt Mullenweg have said that it's
easier it's easier to spot patterns in
this book than in any other book that
I've put together so that allows you
then and me to put together a bespoke
toolkit of your own for any challenge
any opportunity that you might have in
front of you this has some type of
tactic or routine or tool that you can
apply immediately and it's intended to
be used that way this is a reference
book it's also a in case of emergency
break glass book that you can digest in
tiny 5 to 7 page increments it's not a
tizzy this is a choose you're on an
adventure book so that is how it came
together
I didn't plan to put it together it just
needed to come together for me and
hopefully you will find it as useful as
I have hey guys if you're enjoying the
tips and tactics and how-to on this
channel or in the podcast the Tim
Ferriss show I made this for you try the
mentors short advice from the best in
the world
this is the book that I wanted to read
so I went out and I put it together
created a dream list 130 of the best at
what they do people who are icons
legends and ask them all the same
questions these are people in some cases
I wanted to reach out to my whole life
ranges from many many billionaires
cofounders of every company imaginable
elite athletes ranging from surfing to
tennis to powerlifting everything else
country stars actors directors and you
can spot the pattern so some of my
friends have said this is the easiest to
read most useful book that I've put
together yet so check it out tribal
mentors calm you can find sample
chapters the whole list of mentors
everything tribal mentors calm